[Music]
[Music] Even though
I have poor eyesight, I wonder if I should buy an iron arrow. The elven
professor is dangerous, so don't worry about it. Do something about it. I'll
think about it now. O merciful
Mother Goddess, please protect us.  Please
protect me with your strength,
right now, my Masasaurus on the river.
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] If
this continues, I
'll sink. The goblins are different. I heard that the sea goblins are
attacking the fishing grounds.  But the sea
goblins, at least call them Homopisshins. There's no way a
great god who came from the sea of ​​stars would destroy our fishing grounds.So, do you
know the cause of the decrease in fish numbers?I thought I
could help you with your suspicions.  I think
the cause is Shiserpent, Shiserpent. Is
n't that something
that was sent there from somewhere? Well, even if the
movement of the stars is disturbed, in any case, it's
not a goblin. We should go home.
[Music]
Ka
OG